zusammen einen schönen abend bei zdf
heute live mit ihren live stream zu
aktuellen diskussion und ereignissen den
nächsten tagen gucken alle oder
zumindest viele in die usa
in drei tagen soll joe biden als neuer
präsident der vereinigten staaten
vereidigt wären werden und normalen
zeiten würde donald trump als lahme ente
gelten also als präsident ohne macht der
ist nur noch darauf wartet dass er
abgelöst wird aber unter donald trump
ist ja so gut wie nichts normal er hat
zwar gesagt dass er den weg freimachen
wird für eine neue administration
aber er tut das nicht ohne widerstand
müssen wir feststellen den leisten dann
vor allem für ihn seine anhänger das
haben wir vor zwei wochen am sechsten
januar gesehen als zahlreiche menschen
das state capitol in washington dc
gestürmt haben das war eine wirklich
ziemlich krasse bilder die um die welt
gegangen sind und für heute wurde zu
neuen protesten aufgerufen nicht in
washington dc unbedingt sondern verteilt
über das ganze land
die anhänger von trump wurden dazu
aufgerufen von verschiedenen gruppen
sich zu den state capitals zu bewegen
also quasi zu den landesparlamenten der
einzelnen bundesstaaten und dort zu
protestieren
wir sprechen darüber heute meiner
kollegin an dieser jung die ist vor ort
für uns in washington und nicht der
politikwissenschaftlerin kathrin kluba
sprung von der harvard kennedy school
fragen kommentare wie immer erkennt das
innen die dafür vorgesehenen spalten
oder an zdf wollte zdf.de ich versuche
dann rein zu nehmen was wir können und
meine erste frage geht zu meiner
kollegin alicia nach washington dc 10
aus bei dir heute morgen wurde heute
mittag besser gesagt heute mittag genau
du sagst es ist tatsächlich ruhig heute
man also bislang ist es ruhig man hat
aber schon damit gerechnet eigentlich im
vorfeld und dazu wurde ja auch online
immer wieder aufgerufen das also heute
proteste stattfinden
dass es zuvor gesagt also in allen 50
landes und bundes staats hauptstädten
und da und den kapitän nicht stehe jetzt
hier in washington dc vor dem kapitol wo
also auch am letzte woche mittwoch also
der sturm aufs kapital stattgefunden hat
und jetzt ist hier aber wirklich alles
abgeriegelt also es gleicht fast einer
festung hier hinter mir ihr könnt sehen
sind also die soldaten der nationalgarde
der nation
gerade stationiert und ich höre übrigens
gerade dass die verbindung zu dir
abgebrochen ist ich hab das gemerkt weil
ein zeichen kommt dass unsere verbindung
nicht mehr steht aber bist du mich dass
ich zurück gerufen werde aus der regie
würde ich noch mal ganz kurz beschreiben
also wie die stimmung heute ist es sind
also jogger und spaziergänger wirklich
auf der straße unterwegs sind jetzt
hören wir uns auch wieder und schauen
sich also die die situation hier vor ort
an aber bislang ist alles ruhig ist
wurde ein mann heute festgenommen der
trug also eine waffe und hatte relativ
viel munition dabei aber das war jetzt
hier ein bisschen außerhalb der szenerie
und er wurde festgenommen weil er also
auch gar keine legale bescheinigung für
diese waffe hatte und das ist aber
vielleicht auch dass er noch als letzten
zusatz so ein bisschen die angst die
sorge dass hier also auch einzeltäter
tatsächlich was versuchen könnten hier
in der stadt und auch zu einer operation
am mittwoch also die situation ist
angespannt ich hoffe du kannst dich
wieder hören
ja funktioniert super dann gucken wir
aber erstmal auf die bilder die uns
unser kollege benjamin daniel
zusammengeschnitten hat denn der hat
noch ein paar mehr eindrücke aus der
angespannten lage in den vereinigten
staaten zu uns es ist die ruhe nach dem
sturm und sie ist trügerisch beton
barrieren meter hohe zäune tausende
bewaffnete nationalgardisten das capitol
in amerikas hauptstadt ist drei tage vor
der amtseinführung des neuen präsidenten
so gut abgesichert wie wohl noch nie
die angst vor weiteren ausschreitungen
ist groß nicht nur hier auch in den
einzelnen bundesstaaten stellt man sich
auf mögliche unruhen ein was man
verstehen muss ist dass der sturm auf
das kapitol in den augen derer die ihn
maßgeblich organisiert haben ein erfolg
war
das hat sie ermutigt neue pläne zu
schmieden um auch zukünftige
veranstaltungen zu stören
allerdings senden die behörden mit den
jetzigen sicherheitsmaßnahmen eine klare
botschaft und nach allem was meine
quellen sagen haben einige radikale
organisationen bereits entschieden sich
zurückzuhalten
rund um das kapitol ist man diesmal
jedenfalls gut vorbereitet die tribüne
ist fertig das sicherheitskonzept
engmaschig tausende nationalgardisten
stehen bereit
nicht nur sie hoffen dass dies nun
wirklich die ruhe nach dem sturm ist und
nicht wieder ein neuer aufzieht und
darüber spreche ich meiner kollegin
alissa jung die steht genau dort vor dem
kapitol in washington
alisa hast du eine erklärung dafür dass
es doch relativ ruhig bleibt im land
sind das tatsächlich nur die vielen
soldaten die jetzt zum beispiel bei deal
hinter dir stehen
die sind es natürlich auch das hat hier
schon der enormen abschreckende wirkung
also auch auf den plätzen wo man sich
normalerweise versammeln würde der
freedom plaza hier in washington das war
ja so ein ort wo also tram fans sich
gerne versammelt haben der ist weit
verbreitet weitläufig abgesperrt
weiträumig abgesperrt aber es hat noch
andere gründe denn man muss ja auch
sagen in den letzten tagen wurden
beispielsweise plattformen wie paula
also das waren plattformen wo sich eben
viele getummelt haben von den brautpreis
bis eben zu tram fans und eben auch
viele menschen aus der rechten szene
das im plattformen die jetzt hier nicht
mehr funktionieren die also runter
gefahren wurden außerdem wurde ja auch
wie wir alle
der präsident bei twitter beispielsweise
gebannt also es gibt viele kanäle auf
denen man sich sonst eigentlich vernetzt
hätte die jetzt so nicht mehr
funktionieren dass es der zweite grund
und der dritte grund es aber auch dass
viele beispielsweise jetzt auch der
anführer der brautpreis gesagt hat
versammelt euch eben nicht versammelt
euch nicht kommt noch nicht zusammen
weil das ist eine falle so wurde es
genannt das ist eine falle um euch dort
quasi festzunehmen um euch jetzt für den
aufstand auch das capitol verantwortlich
zu machen also kommt lieber nicht
zusammen wir werden an einem anderen tag
zu einem anderen zeitpunkt also wieder
protestieren und unsere wut auf die
straße bringen man ist aber natürlich
hier vorsichtig und vorbereitet nach
allem was da eben letzte woche schief
gegangen ist
es war schon eine ich sage mal
interessante sichtweise daraus ist eine
falle zu machen
es gibt hier fragen an die ich erst mal
im statement von andré köhler auf
facebook der meint solange nur die
hampelmänner vom letzten mal am kapitol
auftauchen ist alles gut
schlimmer wird es wenn wirklich krems
cottbus oder ähnliche gestalten da
auftauchen eine frage an dich von
minister auf youtube gibt es nach den
ereignissen der letzten woche schon
neuere erhebungen dazu wie groß der teil
der republikanischen wähler ist der
immer noch diese wahlbetrugs erzählung
von donald trump glaubt dazu jetzt
konkret gibt es jetzt noch nicht die
umfrage die eine sichere quelle die ich
dazu gesehen hätte aber es ist
tatsächlich so dass die umfragewerte von
präsident trump also noch präsident
trump so schlecht so negativ sind zu
diesem zeitpunkt wie sie es noch nie
zuvor waren also es hat schon dazu
geführt jetzt die ereignisse von letzter
woche dass er auf jeden fall an
beliebtheit eingebüßt hat dass es das
eine und das andere ist dann aber doch
auf der anderen seite das immer noch ein
großteil dieses landes der ihn ja auch
gewählt hat schon auch immer noch dieser
dieser mehr glaubt dass die wahl
gestohlen wurde also das lese und höre
ich viel von menschen mit denen ich eben
schon seit monaten in kontakt bin die
tram fans auch sind und die stehen auch
nach wie vor weiter zu ihm und die
glauben vor allem nach wie vor daran
dass adi war über stolen ist also an
diese weiter erzählte lüge und aber auch
eben was da auch ganz klar die den
umlauf macht es immer wieder der satz
also sie wollen das jetzt gar nicht
akzeptieren dass beiden präsident wird
wobei da werden jetzt tatsächlich
nächste woche fakten geschaffen denn er
wird eingeschworen das wird passieren
darüber reden wir gleich noch aber erst
mal vielleicht noch zu diesen an
donald trump man muss ja sagen jump and
ist nicht leicht kämpfen das ist ja so
ein bisschen auch wie hier na also
die menschen die auch zum beispiel
querdenker demos gehen sind nicht alle
rechtsradikal aber es sind
rechtsradikale darunter das ist ja
ähnlich bei trump also es sind nicht
alle gewaltbereit es sind nicht alle
promis ist also klarer rassisten
aber wie groß ist denn der bestandteil
gibt es dazu vielleicht genaue daten von
diesen menschen die tatsächlich bereit
sind nochmal sich vor das kapitol zu
bewegen oder für ihn state capital zu
bewegen mit waffen tatsächlich und dann
zu sagen wir machen die tabula rasa das
war natürlich schon immer der viel viel
kleinere teil und du sagst es richtig
also wirklich kämpfen heißt natürlich
nicht gleich trump wenn das ist ja ganz
klar
und es waren zumindest 40 prozent in
einer blitzumfrage letzte woche die also
auch das verurteilt haben diesen sturm
aufs kapital
nichtsdestotrotz also ja es ist eben ein
kleiner kleinerer teil zumindest in
jedem falle aber in diesen zumindest
auch aufs ganze land verteilt also jetzt
ist es zwar nicht möglich an vielen
orten weil die state kapitals sind wir
sind jetzt einfach geschütztes sind also
nicht nur hier in washington sondern
auch in vielen anderen landesteilen sind
eben sehr viele sicherheitskräfte auf
den straßen und es wurden zäune
errichtet um ihr sell capitals weil es
nach wie vor eben die befürchtung gibt
dass die menge landesweit im ganzen land
also groß genug sein könnte dass ich da
immer wieder auch proteste auf die
straße bewegen also zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt möchten wir aber vielleicht
noch mal kurz festhalten es landesweit
relativ ruhig auf jeden fall es gab also
vereinzelte proteste gestern
und hier in washington dc ist es zur
stunde also in jedem falle sehr ruhig
ich habe mir eine frage noch auf youtube
können wir auch mal zeigen auf dem
bildschirm von onna
ich habe das nicht ich muss ja auch
richtig dass kabel einstecken dann
klappt das auch hier vielleicht mal
probieren liebe kollegen in der regie
das muss man rechnung noch mal kurz sich
um schützenhilfe niklas das einfach also
daniel fff möchte gerne wissen wozu
braucht es 25.000 soldaten wenn der
beliebteste präsident aller zeiten mit
80 millionen wählern ins amt kommt wird
denn von denen niemand da hingehen ich
ergänze jetzt mal die frage um den zum
beispiel zu beschützen oder auch das
kapitol zu beschützen gibt es dagegen
protest zuerst gibt es ja doch bei uns
immer wieder nur dann gehen die einen
auf die straße die anderen verhindern
dass
vielleicht eine sache die auch wichtig
ist zu wissen um das jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen geradezurücken also ja es
stimmt dass sollen also bis zur
integration bis zur amtseinführung von
joe biden um die 25.000 einsatzkräfte
also in washington versammelt sein aber
also auch in normalen zeiten zu einer
amtseinführung wären ich meine die zahl
ist rund 10.000 also wären auf jeden
fall sehr sehr viele einsatz
einsatzkräfte vor ort die wurden jetzt
also natürlich aufgestockt und es sind
jetzt also wirklich noch mal schärfere
sicherheitsmaßnahmen getroffen wurden
wegen der wegen der ereignisse letzter
woche aber auch in normalen zeiten wäre
also natürlich um eine amtseinführung
das sicherheitsaufgebot hoch aber das
ist jetzt natürlich noch höher als sonst
und jetzt für das es vielleicht auch
noch mal eine interessante punkt also
jetzt zur stunde eben heute hier ist es
ruhig aber wir beobachten auch die
nächsten tage
denn es soll eben zur integration auch
wieder zu protesten kommen ob das dann
tatsächlich passiert eben auch wieder
hier der grund wegen des kunden
sicherheitsaufgebots ob die leute
überhaupt durchkommen das ist die große
frage weil man muss sich das mal
vorstellen dass ihr wirklich jetzt die
straßen sind gesperrt es ist teilweise
hier in washington sind brücken gesperrt
also man kommt hier auch nicht weit ich
habe um mit euch jetzt hier zu sprechen
auch mehrfach den platz wechseln müssen
weil man hier einfach auch gar nicht
überall gerade stehen kann und es wird
wird also vermutet dass es am innovation
day zu protesten kommen könnte oder eben
vielleicht auch am tag danach das wäre
ja dann eine woche nach dem sturm auf
das kapital auch da gibt es jetzt also
gerüchte und da kann es natürlich auch
sein dass ich also da protestieren
auf der einen seite tram fans börse aber
dann natürlich auch nicht ran fans
begegnen
wobei es wird ihnen hier sehr sehr
schwer gemacht also das muss man hier
erst mal versuchen hier durchzukommen
und viele proteste sind auch einfach
nicht genehmigt worden beispielsweise
morgen einer hier in der hauptstadt
geplant und er wurde aber auch gar nicht
genehmigt es gibt sie doch mal quasi die
gegen perspektive also dass eine haben
wir gerade gehört die frage also kommen
die nicht um ihn zu unterstützen auf der
anderen seite als umgedreht von maria
rathmann auf facebook also wenn du rund
20.000 bewaffnete soldaten brauchst und
seiner amtseinführung vor dem volk zu
schützen dann bist du sehr
wahrscheinlich nicht vom volk gewählt
worden
oder frage an dich als ich sah was sagst
du dazu
das habe ich genau ja gerade versucht
eigentlich auch schon ein bisschen in
der in der antwort davor abzufangen also
wie gesagt es ist grundsätzlich so dass
hier ein sehr hohes sicherheitsaufgebot
eben installiert ist zu einer
amtseinführung also das war auch in den
letzten jahren und jahrzehnten nie
anders jetzt wird es natürlich mehr
aber es sind ja auch einfach mehr weil
das eben letzte woche so so so schlecht
funktioniert hat und weil einfach da ihm
sehr viel schief gelaufen ist um das
kapitol zu schützen also in dem fall
glaube ich ist das ja ist es so nicht
ganz richtig wie die frage also bisschen
zugespitzt formuliert war
denn im prinzip ist es ja so natürlich
muss die amtseinführung konzept sich
geschützt werden aber sie wird auch
deshalb jetzt natürlich besser geschützt
weil man nicht mehr möchte dass sich
also so etwas wiederholt wie letzte
woche und die frage ist halt auch ob das
wirklich das volk ist was sich dann
dahin stellt und anfängt eine offizielle
veranstaltung zu stören und dann das
kapital zu stürmen weil dieser vielen
dank wenn etwas passiert bleibst du auf
standby und für sonst berichten
ansonsten wünsche ich dir noch einen
schönen sonntag nach washington
die große frage in den usa ist aber auch
weiterhin wer war das eigentlich der
dort ins kapitol oder die oder das
abitur gestürmt sind wer steckt dahinter
und auch da haben wir nochmal ein stück
von meinem kollegen benjamin daniel der
hat sich auf spuren zugemacht
auch eineinhalb wochen nach den
ausschreitungen geht die suche nach
antworten und den drahtziehern weiter
warum war das gelände so leicht
zugänglich wie kann es sein dass die
randalierer sowohl an der west- als auch
an der ostseite des gebäudes so einfach
eindringen konnten
täglich tauchen immer noch neue fotos
videos und hinweise auf mittlerweile ist
beispielsweise klar dass dutzende
menschen vor ort waren die in der fbi
datenbank als potenzielle terroristen
gelistet sind
auch steht die frage im raum ob es
helferinnen und helfer im innern gab
ich habe am vortag der ausschreitungen
gesehen dass kongressabgeordnete
besucher des capitol geführt haben
das wirkte auf mich wie eine
erkundungstour für den nächsten tag
die ermittlungen gehen also in alle
richtungen auch deshalb müssen die
abgeordneten beim betreten der kammer
nun durch metalldetektoren gehen um ganz
sicher zu sein dass niemand eine waffe
laut experten gibt es in den usa
mittlerweile mehrere zehntausend
menschen die potenziell gewaltbereit und
empfänglich dafür sind von radikalen
organisationen mobilisiert zu werden es
wird also auch künftig eine große
herausforderung sein mit diesem
schlummernden radikalismus umzugehen und
wäre der jump administration ist die
zahl dieser leute deutlich gestiegen
wir können nur hoffen dass mit dem
jetzigen wechsel auch irgendwann wieder
so etwas wie normalität einkehrt und die
leitplanken die uns unsere verfassung
gibt wieder zurechtgerückt werden
das zurechtrücken ist zumindest hier am
kapitol schon abgeschlossen die
aufarbeitung der beispiellosen
ausschreitungen hingegen wird nicht nur
die usa noch lange beschäftigen und
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit der
politikwissenschaftlerin kathryn wood
von der harvard kennedy school in
cambridge massachussetts ein schwieriger
name den nicht manchmal verstolpert aber
jetzt hat es geschafft hallo frau kramp
hallo
jetzt haben wir gerade schon gesehen da
sind viele leute im hintergrund die das
ganze mit angefeuert haben was ist denn
noch bekannt über die ich sage mal
hintermänner die vielleicht nicht
tatsächlich da rein gerannt sind aber
die das ganze mit angefeuert haben
wer das erste ist dass wir jetzt ganz
klar wissen dass dieser anschlag auch
das pulsierende herz amerikas nicht von
oben her kam das hat eben schon
angekündigt wir wissen inzwischen wie
sehr diese gruppe organisiert war
teilweise mit ja mit köpfchen im ohr die
einander wirklich zugerufen haben wie
sie denn nun rein kommen welche fenster
einzuschlagen haben und das fbi geht
inzwischen vielerlei spuren nach
natürlich auch im internet aber auch in
den dark web foren wo gerade solche
quasi strategischen oder taktischen tag
selber ausgetauscht wurden wurden als es
wirklich danken blick und das andere
wegen der starken gibt ja auch ja ich
kann die gute ernte wohl sehr stark
darauf geschaut wird ist wie welche
gruppe
innerhalb des nationalen
sicherheitsrates oder eben sogar bis in
den kongress und senat haben diesen
anschlag überhaupt erst ermöglicht im
beitrag hatten sie eine
kongressabgeordnete die davon sprach
dass jetzt eben diese führung gegeben
hat durch das kapitol
es gab eben auch verschiedene
abgeordnete die während des anschlags
getwittert haben wo sich denn der
vizepräsident gerade befinde wo sich die
sprecherin des repräsentantenhauses
gerade befinde also geografisch wirklich
wir denken vor
vor dem war er vor dem kapitol wo herr
kind quasi sein ende finden sollte so
hatten dass die demonstranten für sich
formuliert das sind natürlich alles
unglaublich besorgniserregende
erkenntnisse die drei jetzt zutage
kommen
und insofern hat das fbi alle hände voll
zu tun gerade diesen ja diesen neun
fällen nachzugehen
jetzt haben wir gerade ein bisschen ton
aussetzer ich hoffe das legt sich gleich
wieder ansonsten müssen wir vielleicht
verbindung noch mal neu aufbauen jetzt
haben sie das gerade öfter mal einen
anschlag genannt und da habe ich hier
eine ich sag mal divergierende meinung
auf youtube können wir kurz mal zeigen
von luca schmidt
er möchte nämlich wissen wieso
überdramatisiert man das eigentlich so
wegen black lips matter hat halb amerika
gebrannt und der sturm auf das kapitol
war ja kein terroranschlag es gibt jetzt
hier in den kommentaren schon gegen
rhede gegen luca war vielleicht können
sie tatsächlich das noch mal aus ihrer
sicht als politikwissenschaftlerin
einordnen warum sie das einen anschlag
nennen ein anschlag stellt man sich in
der regel immer ein bisschen anders
freude explodiert war es und dann sind
menschen tut das ist super die sagen wir
die alltags einordnung von anschlag
so jetzt haben wir sie gerade gar nicht
mehr fragt lieber 11 druck ich würde mal
folgendes vorschlagen jetzt spielmann
die nächste mazda geht es nämlich um es
im payment und in der zeit bauen sie die
verbindung zu ihnen noch mal neu auf
damit das hoffentlich besser
funktioniert also wir schauen erst mal
kurz an es gab ja nach diesem sturm auf
das kapitol viele menschen die donald
trump als verantwortlichen gesehen haben
die ihm quasi eine mitschuld oder die
komplette schuld gegeben haben weil er
die menschen aufgefordert hat richtung
kapitol zu ziehen es gibt als konsequent
ein im pitch mend verfahren also ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen ihn und
wie das abläuft erklärt uns der liebe
gott das verfahren dauert vermutlich
länger als tramp überhaupt im amt ist
nämlich bis 20 januar folgen hätte es
trotzdem sollte der senat mit
zweidrittelmehrheit für eine
amtsenthebung stimmen er könnte
privilegien verlieren die einem ex
präsidenten normalerweise zu stehen eine
pension über jährlich 200.000 us dollar
für den rest seines lebens ein
reisebudget über eine million dollar
jährlich die übernahme seiner
krankenversicherung und ein
staatsbegräbnis
allerdings ist juristisch umstritten ob
ein präsident diese privilegien auch
verliert wenn das
amtsenthebungsverfahren erst nach seiner
amtszeit abgeschlossen wird das gab es
ja noch nie und müsste wahrscheinlich
vor gericht entschieden werden
möglich wäre auch das tram zukünftig
keine politischen ämter mehr ausüben
darf
eine kandidatur bei der
präsidentschaftswahl 2024 wäre damit
hinfällig
dafür bräuchte es nach der amtsenthebung
eine zusätzliche abstimmung im senat für
die aber eine einfache mehrheit reicht
fest steht mit der präsidentschaft endet
auch trumps immunität dann kann er
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden etwa
wegen anstiftung zum aufstand und zwar
egal ob eine amtsenthebung gelingt oder
nicht
und darüber sprechen wir weiter mit der
politikwissenschaftlerin kathrin krüger
r spruch von der harvard kennedy school
in cambridge massachussetts das habe ich
doch das war nur schild die verbindung
steht hoffentlich wieder das heißt wir
können sie das ja gut die frage war
gerade ja ist das ein anschlag oder
nicht gewesen
es war auf jeden fall ein anschlag
erstes mal ist diese symbolik natürlich
nicht von irgendwoher gewählt das haben
wir natürlich auch in deutschland im
september gesehen als ist die
protestierenden oder die sogenannten
querdenker bis auch die stufen des
reichtags geschafft haben mit einer
flanke und einer symbolik die das dritte
reich repräsentiert hat das sagen wir
hier ähnlich gesehen und vor allen
dingen auch das niveau der organisation
also das ganze war und das hat man ja
jetzt in den interviews mit
verschiedenen beteiligten gehört als
sturm auf das kapitol geplant angeheizt
vom präsidenten der in den stunden vor
diese marge zum kapitol also vom weißen
haus zum kapitol wirklich jetzt zu
dieser gewalt und die diesen
gewalttätigen den gewalttätigen
ausschreitungen aufgerufen hat nicht nur
er sondern sein sohn modigliani und
diverse unterstützer aber sie nur gesagt
gebt mal hin und feuert unsere mutigen
seine senatoren an die haben ja nicht
gesagt rente rhein und im anschluss
auseinander er gut aber den juli hat
gesagt wir müssen recht und gesetz mit
gewalt wieder herstellen also wie ist
das anders auszulegen als das als die
bilder die wir da gesehen haben und wir
wissen inzwischen wie gesagt auch aus
den internet vorgänger
ob sie nun über par oder verschiedene
andere soziale medien ausgetauscht
wurden dass das schon ein sehr geplanter
anschlag war mit kern funktionären
innerhalb dieser masse das ist das ist
deutlich anders
als eine friedrich friedliche oder
friedlich angesetzte serie von
demonstrationen wie wir sie im sommer im
ganzen land gesehen habe
jetzt haben wir gerade gesehen es gibt
dieses impeachment verfahren dieses
amtsenthebungsverfahren das ein relativ
bürokratischer und nicht unkomplizierter
akt ist mit vielen fragezeichen was
danach passiert wie sehen sie die
chancen das ist tatsächlich jetzt zu
einem verfahren kommt das dann als
resultat hat dass donald trump
entmachtet wird vielleicht auch dann
nachdem joe biden schon eingeführt wurde
als präsident
also das sind jetzt viele verschiedene
teile über die wir reden müssen die zum
teil auch im beitrag schon an kam damit
quasi der präsident wie er jetzt noch
ist und heißt und scham nie wieder die
höchste machtposition amerikas einnehmen
kann oder bzw sich überhaupt in
irgendeiner position wählen könnte
müsste es zwei abstimmungen geben als
teil des appeasement verfahrens im senat
aber sobald der prozess der
amtsenthebung im senat beginnt ruhen
alle anderen senats geschäfte und so
gibt es natürlich für die republikaner
auf sie nun ja nur mitte der mittel rot
also konservativen republikaner sind
oder quasi radikalisierte von trump
radikalisierte republikaner sind tattoos
holly und andere abgeordnete gibt es
zumindest einen weg diesen ganzen
prozess hinauszuzögern und dann
natürlich den am anfang von joe biden
sehr schwer zu machen denn wir denken
auch mal daran dass alle kern figuren
des kabinetts von joe biden durch einen
senats prozess müssen da gibt es auch
eine anhörung sie müssen die zustimmung
der mehrheit des senats haben damit das
kabinett überhaupt die arbeit aufnehmen
kann
und so ist es für joe biden einerseits
vielleicht teilt er die einstellung der
demokraten dass das geahndet werden muss
was vor anderthalb wochen am kapitol
stattfand und wozu quasi dieser
präsidentin startschuss gegeben hat aber
umgekehrt wird es eben doch den anfang
seiner amtszeit deutlich schwerer machen
er wird nur über die präsidentielle
macht handeln können zumindest in den
ersten wochen oder in der ersten woche
wenn dieses verfahren denn so
stattfindet denn es sind einfach
bestimmte regeln von der verfassung
vorgegeben wie solch ein verfahren
ablaufen soll
also alles hoch komplex sehr sehr
schwierig die situation
und tatsächlich auch die amtsübernahme
von joe biden hier ist eine frage die
finde ich gar nicht so schlecht also
wirklich die habe ich noch nicht
gestellt deswegen aber sie ist so
einfach von crazy 17 03 wie bekommt
beiden trump aus den köpfen der leute
raus ich meine wenn trump selbst noch in
der ersten woche oder den ersten wochen
seiner amtszeit von joe biden immer noch
so präsent ist dann ist doch im grunde
der staat schon fast vermasselt oder ja
ich glaube das ist jetzt genau die frage
die sich alle stellen das erste ist dass
donald trump weg muss aus den medien
also er muss quasi und das haben wir
schon gesehen wie twitter facebook ihm
quasi den haaren den direkten bezug zu
seinem wahlvolk abgedreht haben die ihm
die plattform entzogen haben das hat
schon viel gebracht es ist deutlich
ruhiger geworden im land aber umgekehrt
muss es natürlich auch auf weitere ebene
stattfinden und das was der präsident
der neue präsident beiden jetzt leisten
möchte besonders wenn es um die ganze
frage wirtschaftshilfen um die korona
pandemie richtige gesundheitspolitik und
natürlich wie wir das eben in
deutschland auch haben wie kommen die
impfstoffe an die amerikaner die diese
dringend brauchen wenn er das schnell
hinbekommen kann sich das land insgesamt
beruhigt dann wären doch jedenfalls die
gemäßigten republikaner zumindest
einfach mal eher davon zu überzeugen
dass sich doch jetzt alles vielleicht
nicht zum guten
oder vielleicht nicht ganz in ihrem
politischen sinne wendet aber zumindest
doch so das ist ein vorankommen geben
kann in den usa das heißt sobald es
ermöglicht werden in diesen ganzen
großen fragen jetzt schnell beherzt und
vor allen dingen effektiv handeln zu
können so eine große aufgabe jetzt habe
ich hier verschiedene themenfelder die
ich mache gerne beackern würde weil ich
sehe es gibt richtig viele fragen bei
euch die versuche weiter zu reichen also
einmal hängt natürlich viel davon ab bei
diesem amtsenthebungsverfahren wie sich
die republikaner aufstellen spricht die
republikaner im senat ob die da
mitmachen oder dass das blockieren
jetzt fragt ihr markus lanz
ähnlichkeiten mit moderatorin sind
ausgeschlossen
auf youtube ich verstehe nicht warum die
republikaner immer noch zu trump halten
was haben sie davon
also wer ist nicht auch für die
versorgung der mann einfach verschwindet
donald trump hat etwas geschafft was wir
auch in den vereinigten königreich bei
becks gesehen haben er hat weder
motiviert wie früher nie gewählt haben
und wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
amerika ein in dem sinne unter
beteiligtes bei beteiligungs land ist
wenn bei uns im schnitt leicht 70
prozent 75 prozent der deutschen wähler
noch wählen gehen war es in amerika
immer um die unteren 60 prozent das hat
sich in den letzten in der gerade in den
letzten zwei wahlen doch deutlich
verändert und donald trump hat wähler
ausgemacht die und zwar nicht nur quasi
an der wahlurne für diesen kandidaten
ein stehen sondern in dem komplett ein
neues jahr ein neues lebensgefühl dieser
compiz muss ist für sie ein neues
lebensgefühl das ist die erfüllung einer
bestimmten definition des amerikanischen
individualismus in dem sie sich wieder
gehört und abgeholt fühlen und diese
wähler sind sehr potenzielle oder sehr
eine sind eine starke wählergruppe und
es hat eben dann in bestimmten bereichen
americas geografischen bereichen grade
stellen sie zurzeit die potenzielle
republikanische mehrheit für einige
abgeordnete und deshalb kann ein donald
trump auch wenn er nicht mehr im amt ist
für die republikaner brandgefährlich
werden er und sein sohn haben beide auf
der veranstaltung letzte woche gesagt
wenn ihr nicht mitmacht mit der
tramlinie denn es ist jetzt die
traumtour republikanische partei so hat
donald juni als letzte woche noch mal
definiert dann stellen wir euch in den
vorwahlen trumpet kandidaten an die
seite und dann werdet ihr ausgehebelt
das heißt das leute fragen samstag in
berlin
hier kommt tatsächlich auch eine frage
dazu nähe von stefan es auf youtube der
meint also topfit seinen sohn zur
nächsten wahl ins rennen schicken
das heißt dass im pitch mend verfahren
ist für die katz also im grunde kann man
jetzt sagen dass der trump clan dabei
ist das amerikanische system zu
übernehmen
ein unternehmer mal geht es darum die
republikanische partei von ihnen
aufeinander zu nehmen und komplett auf
linie zu bringen
das hat jetzt schon familie schon sehr
gut geschafft wir denken an den
republikanischen partei tag des sommers
zurück wo die republikanische partei
erstmalig in ihrer geschichte überhaupt
kein parteiprogramm geschrieben hat denn
der mann war das programm
und wenn ihr mann das klang gerade erst
sich torturen eben ganz kann
und was wo wir jetzt gerade sehen wie
sich die republikanische partei quasi
entkernt oder spaltet gibt es bestimmte
personen auf bestimmten wahlkreisen wo
gerade eben die tram schon wähler sehr
sehr stark sind und wo es um den reinen
blanken machterhalt geht also um den um
diese sehen ab sitze also dass das ist
natürlich die quasi schlagkräftigeren
positionen in einigen amerikanischen
kongress system und diese wollen sich
wiederum ganz klar und für die hilft es
wenn ein autokratischer duktus weiterhin
teil der diskussion ist das sind quasi
inzwischen so kann man das sagen wenn
ich an bestimmte figuren denke an george
holland cruz das sind inzwischen
wirkliche antidemokraten im herzen der
amerikanischen demokratie und wenn die
weiter befeuert werden sowohl von der
tram familie von außen und von und das
ist noch mal das wichtigste im
amerikanischen system von geldgebern und
ein donald trump auch wenn er quasi
außer amt und würden ist gelder an
verschiedene schlüsselstellen bringen
kann um wahlkämpfe zu steuern
dann kann es ja wohl sein dass wir noch
lange nicht mit dem campus abheben kann
das sind jetzt zwei fragen die ich hätte
sie haben gerade gesagt man muss
aufhören vor allem die medien bespricht
wir hier auch in deutschland die
wirtschaft zu sprechen und ihm eine
bühne zu geben aber wenn er parallel ich
sag mal seine tochter ivanka aufbaut da
gibt es ja auch schon fragezeichen ob
sie vielleicht kandidieren könnte wenn
er seinen sohn donald china aufbaut wenn
er seine wing man aufbaut die sie gerade
genannt haben also auch sehr rechts
orientierte menschen dann ist es doch im
grunde sinnlos wenn man aufhört wenn ein
zu reden wenn die anderen sich in
position bringen ich glaube dass
wichtiger ist über das phänomen zu
sprechen und ich glaube was wir über die
jahre die vier jahre in der wir wirklich
geschockt waren in europa wie dieser
mann raubbau an der amerikanischen
demokratie treiben kann und wie er damit
auch noch so erfolgreich sein kann das
ist quasi das ganze enormen korsett aus
einem doch aus der ältesten demokratie
der welt raus blut dann muss man sich
mit dem phänomen beschäftigen und wir
haben uns glaube ich viel zu sehr
konzentriert auf das was auf der
washingtoner bühne sich abspielt aber
das sehen wird das natürlich macht sich
nach irgendwo nach washington verlagert
aber das politische entscheidung und
doch innerhalb des ganzen landes
getroffen werden also ich denke wie
gesagt an
die nachwahl und natürlich im rennen
nach 2022 die in den sogenannten midterm
wahl wo 34 senatssitze neu besetzt
werden und das komplette
repräsentantenhaus es geht jetzt schon
wieder um was und das heißt die trump
familie an sich wird vielleicht keine
große rolle spielen denn oder keine
große gruber definierte rolle spielen in
den einzelpersonen also donald banker
weil nämlich dann das macht geschaffen
davon wäre jetzt quasi die partei
übernehmen darf nach innen das wollen
die berufspolitik garten zweifel für
sich entscheiden aber sie wollen
natürlich auf der basis von dem was
donald trump aufgebaut hat über die
letzten vier jahre
das ist ihr plateau zum erfolg und ich
glaube wir werden wirklich noch sehen
wie die republikanische partei nach
innen zerfleischt aber oder versucht
jedenfalls bestimmte teile zu retten
damit sie 2022 doch ein wahlsieg
einfahren könnten also versuchen können
gerade repräsentantenhaus und senat
umzugehen das wird unglaublich schwierig
weil diese fraktionen fraktionen teile
dieser republikanischen partei eben
jetzt so gespalten sind geht man weiter
den traum schon weg oder versucht man
den konservatismus den traditionellen
amerikanischen konservatismus wieder zu
retten und ich glaube das sind die ganz
großen gräben die zurzeit in der
republikanischen partei sich auch tun
ich habe ihnen geraten ganz amüsanten
kommentar von the rock auf youtube kurz
mal zeigen bitte der mann über den man
nicht sprechen darf
geht's noch also eine kleine wolke
anspielung das fand ich hübsch
jetzt haben sie aber gerade gesagt frau
klinger spruch geldgeber stecken
dahinter bei donald trump also gerade
dieses ganze amerikanische system ist
sehr auf spenden aufgebaute geben
wirklich einzelpersonen und unternehmen
geben millionen in diese unter in diese
einzelnen wahlkämpfe reihen
donald trump hat auch millionen schon
jetzt eingesammelt aber auf der anderen
seite in ziehen im märz auch unternehmen
die die zusammenarbeiten also ist es
nicht vielleicht auch einfach möglich
dass er so an bedeutung verliert ganzen
system so in sich zusammenbricht war
jetzt zum beispiel die deutsche bank
sagt ich arbeite mit ihr zusammen weil
im mieter kündigen und weil generell
sein ganzes business imperium implodiert
und die geldgeber weg gehen
also ich glaube davon können zumindest
mal ausgehen also donald trump drohen
sobald er das weiße haus verlässt und
zwar immer am mittwoch um 12 uhr die
zivilrechtliche prozesse die ihm
wirklich die luft zum atmen sehr eng
machen können und deswegen gehe ich auch
nicht davon aus dass die traumschiff
familie an sich sich so lange halten
wird aber die bewegung das gedankengut
das radikalisierte autokratische
antidemokratisches gedankengut das hat
diese familie das hat dieser mann und
das hat mit heiner der republikanischen
partei ihnen das land tragen können und
deswegen finde ich das lobenswert wie
sich jetzt gerade amerikanische
unternehmen sich noch einmal genau
anschauen wie passen eigentlich diese
einstellungen zu unserem grundsätzlichen
werten und sie haben es angesprochen es
die republikaner haben quasi aus ihrer
individuellen parteikasse also gerade
bestimmte abgeordnete haben aus ihrer
individuellen wahlkampfkasse millionen
dollar eingebüßt über die letzten zehn
tage und wenn das so weitergeht bzw
parteispenden anders ankommen und
vielleicht auch den demokraten nun zu
fließen weil es wirklich um ganz
grundsätzliche fragen von autoritären
system versus demokratie geht dann
könnte davon doch eine unglaubliche
schlagkraft ausgehen für gerade die
demokraten wahlkampf zu machen wie wir
ihn vielleicht so bisher noch nicht
gesehen haben und donald trump kann
wiederum nur auf die zu über 200
millionen dollar zurückgreifen die es
seit dem 3
november eingenommen hat auf der basis
dieser lüge die wahl wäre illegitimen
oder nicht gerecht gewesen oder ihnen
gestohlen worden wenn er weiterhin
wahlkampf macht beziehungsweise
republikanische partei aber wie lange
donald trump als einzelperson noch
wahlkampf betreiben kann und wie schnell
ihm gerade das oberste gericht in new
york in seinem stab bundesstaat new york
die luft abdrehen kann
das wird interessant zu beobachten sein
so jetzt haben wir viel über trump
geredet dabei müssen wir feststellen da
kommt weil ein neuer mann nämlich joe
biden der ist gewählter präsident der
sonne am mittwoch vereidigt werden also
in drei tagen
und diese inauguration wie das in
amerika heißt also diese amtseinführung
die wird in vielen punkten eine ziemlich
ungewöhnliche veranstaltung und das
ganze hat jan friedrich fischer mal
zusammengefasst
die amtseinführung von beiden als 46
us-präsident sie wird einmalig aus
vielen gründen gerade einmal 1000 gäste
dürfen auf den tribünen platz nehmen
während amerikas hauptstadt einer
festung gleicht ein zwei meter hoher
metallzaun umringt derzeit das capitol
und mehr als 20.000 nationalgardisten
sollen vor ort für sicherheit sorgen
zudem ist die traditionelle parade auf
der pennsylvania avenue abgesagt die
menschen sind auch corona bedingt
aufgefordert am mittwoch zu hause zu
bleiben
doch von dort können sie die geballte
prominenz sehen so wird etwa die pop
ikone lady gaga die nationalhymne singen
besonders ist auch die vereidigung von
kamala herres der ersten schwarzen
vize-präsidentin sie soll ihren amtseid
vor soto mayor ablegen der ersten
richterin am supreme court mit
lateinamerikanischen wurzeln
er wird hingegen nicht dabei sein
donald trump der noch-präsident will
washington vorher verlassen das
symbolische bild für eine friedliche
machtübergabe wird damit fehlen
und darüber spreche ich jetzt noch mal
mit kathrin klug
politikwissenschaftlerin an der kennedy
havard school in cambridge massachusetts
was für ein bundesstaat jetzt haben wir
abgesehen machtwechsel kommt aber unter
großen hindernissen haben sogar schon
gesagt weil es eben dieses
amtsenthebungsverfahren parade noch
wahrscheinlich gibt gegen donald trump
das könnte arbeiten erstmal behindern
aber die große frage ist tatsächlich am
mittwoch wird das alles reibungslos
vonstatten gehen sehen sie diesen
machtwechsel gefährdet also die
machtwechsel an sich nicht mehr
gefährdet der präsident der sein amt am
mittwoch annimmt hat von vornherein und
immer wieder über den letzten wochen
betont er werde der präsident ganz
amerika sein er möchte nicht als
demokratischer präsident per se gelten
das sind so bilde die bemüht er auch aus
dem wahlkampf obama noch mal das wird
eine feier sein es wird eine feier aber
der amerikanischen demokratie sein die
einen ganz deutlichen rabatt wenn wir
alle wissen wie gefährdet die demokratie
an sich ist und das hat man glaube ich
einfach vielleicht nicht so wahr haben
wollen selbst wenn natürlich auch der
fbi vor der wahl im november gesagt hat
die gewalt nach innen also der häusliche
terrorismus ist die größte gefahr für
amerikas nationale sicherheit daher
stehen
das haben wir am anfang dieser sendung
noch mal wieder eindrücklich und
ausdrücklich gesehen 25.000
nationalgardisten um das kapitol und um
das weisse haus quasi herum
um diesen vorgang der normalerweise ein
ganz normaler ein aber ein kern teil
einer demokratie sein muss die
friedliche machtübergabe um dieses
abzusichern
also ich denke wir werden trotzdem trotz
alledem eine feierliche atmosphäre
erleben aber uns allen wird dieser nach
geschmack bleiben denn wie resident wie
wehrhaft wie funktional ist die
amerikanische demokratie gerade noch das
ist eine gute frage die werden wir den
nächsten monaten vielleicht beantwortet
sehen
hier gibt es jetzt auch schon im chat
befürchtungen dass es am nächsten
mittwoch zu toten kommen könnte ich habe
gerade eine nachricht also
kommentar gesehen nach dem motto man
wird die toten zählen müssen
wir hoffen natürlich nicht dass es so
weit kommt aber wir haben es auch von
unserer kolleginnen an dieser jungen am
anfang der sendung gehört es wird
befürchtet dass es zu einzelnen taten
taten kommen könnte wie groß sehen sie
denn da tatsächlich das potenzial das
gewaltpotenzial in dieser in dieser
gruppe hin
ich glaube das potenzial ist groß wir
haben auch vor weihnachten einen
anschlag gesehen der vermutlich in
europa gar nicht so deutlich angekommen
ist aber es hat jemand geschafft sich in
nashville tennessee in einem wohnmobil
in die luft zu sprengen
das hat nicht nur auswirkungen auf
nashville selber sondern eben zum
beispiel auch auf kritische
infrastruktur auf alle telefonleitungen
im inneren dieser stadt und man würde
vielleicht sagen na ja gut an eine stadt
in einem südstaaten was passiert mag das
heißt man aber wenn es um solche dinge
geht die kritische infrastruktur wir
haben gesehen wie timothy mcveigh vor
fast 30 jahren es geschafft hat vor
einem föderalen also ein symbol der
amerikanischen demokratie an
bürokratischen gebäude im föderalen
bürokratie gebäude
er ist ferner building 106 67 menschen
in den tod zu reißen und wirklich gerade
besonders denke daran dass ein
kindergarten in diesem gebäude waren wie
viele kinder gestorben sind und es war
damals eine einzeltat das heißt es kann
reichen eine solche grauenhafte
einzeltat von einer seit einem
radikalisierten menschen
das heißt der fbi der doch fehler
gemacht hat ganz klar fehler über die
letzten zehn tage wird sich jetzt sehr
am riemen reißen müssen und wir dürfen
aber nicht vergessen wie politisiert
inzwischen jede föderale bürokratie ist
wie viele trump anhänger in diesen
organisationen sitzen die auch nicht bis
zum 20
januar aus diesen bürokratien raus
gespielt werden sein müssen also wir
müssen uns doch sorgen machen darüber
was im ganzen land noch passieren könnte
wird es in washington der fall sein
davon gehe ich nicht aus aber natürlich
ist das ganze land sieht sich das ganze
land doch bedroht durch diesen nicht nur
aufkeimenden sondern inzwischen auch
wirklich über das ganze
dann verteilte radikalisiert
wir müssen uns noch mal ganz klar
ansprechen diesen weiß radikalisierten
rechten terror birmas kann man die noch
irgendwie einfangen oder sind die
komplett verloren und man muss hoffen
dass sich vielleicht in der nächsten
generation aussterben sehr gut da sind
wir genau bei den taktiken die der ganze
westen europa jetzt mal mit
eingeschlossen versucht in der
terrorbekämpfung seit jahren aus und
aufzubauen wir denken an al-qaida wir
denken dass wir denken die kapazitäten
von terroristischen organisationen
menschen an sich zu binden wir denken
auch gerade wie es ermöglicht hat
menschen in ihr kalifat zu bringen so
sowie in europa blieben deshalb wiese
sondern im stream zu zu islamismus und
bin ja dann sind die gleichen das sind
die gleichen die fragen jede terror
expertin und jeden terrorexperten auf
der ganzen welt ob sie nun dem zdf
experten peter naumann oder rtl matthée
wissen dazu holen das sind die gleichen
taktik wie mit emotionen gespielt wird
wie menschen isoliert werden von ihrer
gemeinschaft und von ihrem umfeld wie
ihnen das gefühl gegeben wird sie würden
etwas größeres leisten für eine größere
sache einstehen für ein höheres wesen
etc
das sind alles dinge und wir wissen
inzwischen wie radikalisierungsprozess
im internet ablaufen es haben sich
inzwischen generationen von
radikalisierung forscher damit befasst
wie es bei al qaida und wie's
funktioniert hat das sind die gleichen
mechanismen und das heißt eigentlich
wissen wir und zwar nicht seit gestern
sondern die inzwischen seit jahrzehnten
wie man sich gegen solche radikalen
gruppen vorgeht und wie man gerade die
sogenannten loan hilft er ist also diese
einzeltäter fenin lang machen wir ist
das haben wir beim wiener anschlag
wieder gesehen ich denke an die
schrecklichen ereignisse auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt in berlin wir schaffen
es nicht immer aber wir schaffen es
immer öfter und wir müssen uns genau
diese taktiken anschauen und natürlich
auch dann anwenden gegen den terrorismus
der zu hause wächst so eine frage habe
ich am ende noch aus unserer
zuschauerschaft können wir noch mal kurz
zeigen hier auf meinem bildschirm von
nochmals diesmal die hat oder der hat
heute auch schon mal eine frage gestellt
aber ich finde die jetzt auch wirklich
gut dass ich noch mal stellen durch
da gibt es überhaupt konkrete ansätze um
diese massive spaltung zu überwinden und
die usa an eine situation zu bringen in
der sich beide seiten wenigstens auf
eine version der realität einigen können
ich würde sagen wenigstens vielleicht
halbwegs einigen können wir das geht ja
doch teilweise mittlerweile völlig
auseinander
ich glaube das ist die wirklich große
herausforderung denn über den
gesellschaftlichen demografischen und
soziologischen wandel den amerika zeit
besonders in den letzten 30 jahren
besonders schnell vollzogen hat wir
wollen noch mal daran erinnern dass
amerika in den nächsten jahr 30 jahren
25 jahren die erste komplett multi
ethnische multikulturelle supermacht
werden wird wie wir sie so in der
geschichte der welt noch nie gehabt
haben und diese großen veränderungen
haben vielen menschen angst gemacht die
haben sie bloß gestellt oder quasi zu ja
sie haben die zum fraß vorgeworfen
diesen verschiedenen radikalisierten und
radikalisierenden gruppen innerhalb
amerikas und man muss es universo
radikal denken dass medienspektrum in
den usa das narrativ spektrum
wir denken daran dass in den späten 70er
jahren ein gesetz abgesetzt wurde oder
herausgenommen wurde
nachdem was quasi die die medien auf
einer art hippokratischen eid einschwört
medien müssen jetzt nicht mehr faktisch
und richtig berichten dass wurde
rausgenommen und das hat eben einen jahr
einen sogenannten open journalisten
meinungsjournalismus zugelassen
der in amerika jetzt am tag an dem die
tagesordnung bestimmt und da ist dann
eben genau die frage können amerikaner
weil sie in der schule lernen oder durch
zivile bildung lernen wie man solche
meinungen auseinander fakten können
amerikaner das noch und wir sehen in den
letzten paar jahren wie schwierig das
für amerikaner geworden ist wo ich meine
müssen uns auch an die eigene nase
greifen unsere medien für medienpolitik
verändert sich auch so schwieriger ja
die öffentlich rechtlichen medien so zu
erhalten wie wir sie brauchen in einer
demokratie die vierte macht im staat und
das ist in amerika ein wirklich großes
problem
und nur so wenn man wieder findet zu
einer gemeinde
damen faktenlage einer gemeinsamen eines
gemeinsamen verständnisses eine
ausgangslage können doch wirklich die
gespräche wieder stattfinden die dann
das politische handeln auch großer ebene
ermöglichen
ich setze ganz persönlich ganz große
hoffnungen in die städte in amerika in
die bürgermeister 86 prozent der
amerikaner meinen man könne
bürgermeistern als einzigen
volksvertreter noch vertrauen
ich setze also doch noch einiges in die
kraft der amerikanischen nachbarschaft
denn das zusammenleben und in die macht
der amerikanischen städte und ich glaube
da ist 1 keinem der direkten demokratie
der gerade wieder aufleben kann und wenn
das gekoppelt werden kann durch ein
anderes medienverständnis und andere
ansätze in der bildungspolitik das sind
alles langfristige dinge aber das muss
natürlich passieren damit ein ja eine
demokratie längerfristig wehrhaft bleibt
ich würde sagen das klingt nach einem
magath projekt megaprojekt im endeffekt
und ich war gerade sagen den kommentar
pro öffentlich-rechtliche haben wir bei
ihr nicht in auftrag gegeben weil unsere
gesprächspartnerin hat sie einfach so
gesagt aber schön dass sie uns
unterstützen und uns wichtig finden
deswegen haben wir uns ja für mittwoch
auch gleich wieder verabredet bei der
inauguration bei der amtseinführung und
kurz vor 18 uhr geht es hier bei uns los
aber wir werden uns bestimmt auch morgen
oder übermorgen noch ein wiedersehen im
live stream
ich bedanke mich erst mal bei ihnen frau
tvf druck dass sie auch am sonntag zeit
wir uns hatten ich sage euch danke fürs
zu sehen für die vielen fragen und
kommentare und wird sagen dann sehen wir
uns vielleicht morgen oder übermorgen
wieder
bis dahin war es gut und tschüss